exactly as a geometric sequence well
first of all sequence just means that
it's a list okay values and you can see
that the values are separated by a comma
okay so a sequence is a list a series is
actually a sum you're adding them
together you'll see plus signs in
between here but a sequence is a list
and geometric means that we're
multiplying by the same quantity to get
to the next term and then the same
quantity get to the next term et cetera
that term that you're multiplying by to
get to the next term is called the ratio
and we use the letter R for ratio okay
so if you were to take six divided by
three you see how you get two that's a
ratio 12 divided by six see how you're
also getting two that's a ratio so
that's our value now another thing I
want to point out is that this is N
equals one this is N equals 2 N equals 3
that tells you what term that you're on
and then if you look at a sub 1 a sub 2
a sub 3 etc that's the value of that
term so meaning what is the value of the
first term 3 what is the value of the
second term 6 and so on right so now the
question is how do we get a formula for
any term in this geometric sequence well
what you can think about is let's look
at this over here if we want to find the
1 2 3 4 5 6 term N equals 6 we would
start at 3 right and we would multiply
by a ratio 2 as our common ratio once
twice three times four times five times
now you might be saying yourself Mario
how come five this is a sixth term well
because we already are on that first
term we already know this first term
we're just multiplying by the ratio one
last time to get to the sixth term so if
we think about what we just did we took
the first value which is three we
multiply by two and minus one times okay
so in this case that's our formula so a
sub N equals three times 2 to the N
minus 1 now if we wanted to find the
sixth term what we would do is we would
put six in place of n so this would be
three times two to the fifth and we
could simplify that and that's going to
be the value of our sixth term okay now
to write this in a more you know generic
way so that you can use it
here's your formula right here it's a
sub N equals a sub one that's the value
of the first term times R that's your
common ratio that's what you're
multiplying by
to get to the next term to the N minus
one power it's always one less okay so
that's your formula so